INTERVIEWER:
Hi.
Can you tell us your name and
what course you are involved
with?
PROF.
COLEMAN: My name is Charles
Coleman.
I am an assistant professor in
the Aerospace Engineering
Department at MIT and I teach
Systems Engineering and the
Unified Engineering course.
INTERVIEWER:
And can you tell us what is
going on today for this Unified
Engineering Aerial Competition?
PROF.
COLEMAN: Today we are running
the 2004 Unified Aerial
Competition.
There are about 14 teams of
five students each that are
flying their airplanes and
demonstrating their systems.
INTERVIEWER:
How does this relate to the
rest of the Unified course?
PROF.
COLEMAN: Well,
the systems problems and labs
serve two purposes with Unified
Engineering.
The first part is the
laboratories provide an
opportunity for students to
experimentally verify some of
the theoretical principals they
have learned in class.
The second aspect of systems
problems allows us to implement
our conceived designed implement
and operate pedagogy.
And so we have various,
several exercises throughout
the semester where students
actually design,
build and operate small
systems.
INTERVIEWER:
And this is the CDIO component.
Can you say more about CDIO?
PROF.
COLEMAN: Yes.
CDIO stands for Conceive,
Design, Implement and Operate.
It is a pedagogical framework
that we have chosen as an
overarching framework to teach
engineering.
And the principle behind this
is we sort of want to reduce the
gap between what engineers do in
real life and what we teach in
school.
The facts of the matter are
most people, once they graduate
for practical engineers,
spend most of their lives
conceiving, designing,
building and operating things.
So as we teach theoretical
principles, basic engineering
principles, we want students to
be able to apply them in the
framework that they would much
like in their careers.
INTERVIEWER:
OK.
Can you describe what is going
to happen today and what the
students have done to prepare
for this event?
PROF.
COLEMAN: Oh,
yes, that would be a lot of
fun.
I have assigned the students to
design a system.
And I teach a simple
decomposition of systems.
It is not the only one.
And I teach students that
systems are composed of people,
products and procedures that
have to operate together to
deliver value.
And you can sort of think of
value as going in the opposite
direction of money.
Systems are fairly general.
This breakdown works anywhere
for Disney World,
people, product and process,
lawyering, and even to things
like the military.
In particular,
today they have about a set of
four functional requirements,
build a plane,
train a pilot and a crew,
and the task is to fly two
empty laps, land the plane,
load it with anywhere between
one or four eggs,
and then fly as long as they
can with their payload.
And then they also have to
minimize the amount of time that
they spend on the ground loading
the eggs.
So that is what is going to go
on today.
We are going to see how the
students perform based on their
estimates.
INTERVIEWER:
And how long have the students
prepared for this?
PROF.
COLEMAN: Oh,
the students have been working
for approximately nine weeks for
about four hours per week with
five people per team and with
training from us and various
materials and supplies.
INTERVIEWER:
Any predictions about how it is
going to go?
Are we going to see a lot of
spilled eggs do you think?
PROF.
COLEMAN: I hope we don't see a
lot of spilled eggs.
One of the learning objectives
of the course for me is for
every student,
every group to have a
successful systems building
experience.
So a broken egg is not
necessarily a bad thing.
You learn how to build systems
by building systems.
And I think a unique aspect
about this part of the course is
that you can actually learn a
lot from your failures.
INTERVIEWER:
So, in other words,
you cannot learn to build
aircraft without breaking some
eggs.
PROF.
COLEMAN: True.
That is true.
INTERVIEWER:
OK.
Well, thanks for your time and
thanks for sharing your
materials with OpenCourseWare.
PROF.
COLEMAN: Yup.
Thank you.